talking to somebody probably is as  demonic as we think he is Vladimir Putin  and Ukraine as we're doing this  interview he's been issuing more better  Coast threats about using nuclear  weapons yeah from so you're a surprise  do you think he would actually do that  yes and what kind of person is he Putin  do you think  well he's a lot more like everybody else  than anyone thinks you know the notion  that he's Hitler or Stalin that's just  foolish I don't see any evidence for  that at all I mean first of all Hitler  and Stalin were very singular types and  there's a bit of Hitler and stellen and  everyone so you know there's some truth  and that maybe there's more in the  typical Russian everyone really  there's more than a bit really  oh absolutely yeah well why would have  Nazism spread the way it did you know  people think well that's all top down  it's not top down